Este es el corazón de la capital europea
aquí en Bruselas las autoridades esperan
una línea similar a pesar del cambio
político que se abre en Italia
y por supuesto esperamos tener una
cooperación constructiva con las nuevas
autoridades italianas
mientras que la reacción oficial de
Bruselas ha sido escueta París ha sido
menos discreta el presidente macon ha
dicho que acepta los resultados y la
primera ministra ha pedido que se
respeten los valores europeos
en Europa tenemos una serie de valores y
por supuesto estaremos atentos a que
estos valores sobre los derechos humanos
sobre el respeto a los demás en
particular el respeto al derecho al
aborto por ejemplo sean respetados por
todos
pero no todo el mundo ha levantado las
cejas en Europa la ultraderechista
maguin le penn celebró las noticias en
Italia felicitando a los italianos por
resistir las amenazas de una Unión
Europea antidemocrática y arrogante el
director político del Primer Ministro
húngaro también celebró el resultado de
la votación Víctor orván espera trabajar
con la administración entrante de Italia
afín y populista para aliviar la actual
crisis energética del otro lado el
ministro de asuntos exteriores de España
fue de los más pesimistas José Manuel
Álvarez advirtió que en tiempos de
incertidumbre los movimientos populistas
ofrecen soluciones simples a problemas
complejos algo que siempre acaba igual
en catástrofe